as many of you know i'm fascinated by  scams and i just finished watching this  really great six episode documentary  series called inside the mind of a con  artist on curiosity stream uh i i don't  i'm sort of dumbfounded in fact by con  artists and how  they exist and how they continue to do  the things that they do and also how  people fall for them it's really  remarkable and you learn about some of  the uh most successful i guess it's  weird to call it successful but some of  the most successful con artists let me  know in the comments do you think con  artists are smart or not in order to get  away with the things they do and you can  check out the series inside the mind of  a con artist on curiosity stream  curiosity stream is the best streaming  service for documentaries documentaries  of all kinds i love all of them and it's  so cheap a buck 25 a month use the link  in the description or go to  curiositystream  curiositystream.com  david